so guess what the next year is going to
be a lot of losing you know what else
hurts you decide Gary got you and now
you're nice as [ __ ] after being somewhat
neutral to maybe not great and now
you're nicest [ __ ] to your employee and
after nine months they quit and go to a
competitor the first thing you're gonna
think is [ __ ] Gary
that's losing but it's a micro loss we
have to understand what a micro loss is
versus a macro loss you figure that [ __ ]
out you'll be real happy we'll go in the
middle first pick anybody
stand up please and give me your name
please
such a pleasure thank you so I'm trying
really hard to pay attention to where
the attention is we've had a studio
that's been like older demographic
um where social media leads are down by
half of our other computer Studios
um will they pay attention to tick tock
like what are their what are they give
me give me older we talking 70 to 90
no
50 to 70. so where is it
back to people just got it so couple
things
Facebook
is like unbelievably good right now
because all the big companies canceled
Mark Zuckerberg and all the little
companies are a little scared with the
way it's going right now in December so
all the money is out of the system so
the organic reach is through the roof
just so everybody knows the way social
works is there's a feed
it's just inventory there's people's
attention all of us and then they fill
in if they don't have ads organic fills
it just people posting which is what I'm
trying to get you to do it if they have
ads those people will take precedent
that's how they make money but if the
demand is huge everything works so on
Tick Tock right now there's so much
consumption both ads and organic are
working on Facebook it went so crazy ads
for so long which is why their stock
price was so high for so long that it
was hard for us to get organic reach
Facebook fan page which a lot of you
might remember and again you can write
this down Google how do I build a
Facebook fan page if you haven't and
more importantly Facebook reels which
are similar to tick tocks and Instagram
reels have exploded Facebook dominates
50 to 70. as far as tick tock tick
tock's biggest growth right now is 50 to
70. because so many grandkids are
getting their grandparents on it you
know this a lot of you here know your
parents are on Tick Tock and they're in
that demo or you yourself are in that
demo so yes they will because it's
coming but Facebook reels are huge but
then there's also best practices for
example
every one of these social media accounts
says I'm sure you know even if you're
not deep in it has a place where you can
put a link
of your home page or whatever like it's
all strategy like that link is the most
important like where are you sending
that most people are on mobile a lot of
people I see in this SMB franchisee
World they'll put a link that isn't even
mobile optimized so they saw the tick
tock or the Instagram post but then they
click the link because they're
interested but then like the whole
experience is crap and they're out so is
your website mobile optimized should you
send it to a website you create that
just has a phone number and an email
like you have to be it's you have to be
smart that's part of it but I think
Facebook reels is a real place for you
to focus on
and again that 15 comes 15 posts leg
comes in the mindset of three times five
three posts a day
Instagram
YouTube shorts has exploded if you know
what that is YouTube shorts again you
can write that down and Google it tick
tock LinkedIn has become a monster
LinkedIn for this industry because I
made a post six months ago about it and
have been reached out by several people
in Fitness with locations LinkedIn is
acting like Facebook did seven years ago
so you get a LinkedIn account you just
post Fitness and then you make it
tailored to the business world right
think you have no time because you're a
busy executive 15 like you start playing
with the context so that's that you got
it I think LinkedIn would also be strong
for 50 to 70 is really strong on
LinkedIn but again context matters so if
you know you're posting on LinkedIn you
may make a reference of burnout at work
whereas if you're posting on Tick Tock
you might make you want to keep up with
your kids and your grandkids it's the
psychology that matters
all right let's go over there
you'll be next
hi
what's your name Sandra Sandra nice to
meet you
you mentioned something about
equity for employees yep can you share
some examples of what that sounds like
every time I've talked so the context I
brought that up in Sandra was I have a
lot of friends and entrepreneurs and
people that follow me that complain
about their employees not working as
hard as them
that statement makes me want to jump out
a window
and what I say to them is if you want
your employee to work as hard as you
they should be your equal partner nobody
making 19 an hour should work as hard as
the person that owns a hundred percent
of the company
so what does it look like every time I
tell them that none of them give Equity
to their employees
they just get a little more comfortable
with being comfortable with not
everybody working as hard as them as far
as a different question there's a ton of
startups I'm involved with that do give
Equity to their two or three or four
most important employees they make that
Equity vet over vest excuse me over two
three four years to create retention
because they want to keep those key
people and a lot of times the equity
pool for a company is 10 or less
you're welcome
hey
Frontline sales employees I want
guarantee pay and they don't care about
thermometers I apologize for some reason
I'm struggling to hear can you struggle
all the time yeah can you hear me now
better yes
and bonuses and this has been going on
for a few years and talk to some of
their owners about this too and just
wondering if there's a better way to
motivate people or if I'm not wearing
the right people
um I think it's back to the reality of
options
you know with covid I love when people
are like I had an interview the other
day and the person's like I've been
through a hard time 25 years I've been
already through hard times I I had to
get through coven I'm like you mean when
the government sent you a check and you
bought dumb [ __ ]
so I think what you're dealing with is
the environment we just lived through
where people have so many options they
were like I'm gonna take advantage of
you I don't want to live on Merit I want
to make as much as possible and then if
I do nothing who cares I really do
believe today there's been a ton of
layoffs at Fortune 500 land I think
December is gonna and January gonna be
quite ugly and I think you're gonna find
yourself having way more people willing
to work on commission of course you
might want to tweak base and commission
structure if you're not finding people
that want to get there but it's casting
a wider net and realizing that the
Market's changing
they just had so many other options of
people willing to do that and so they
were going for that but the frothiness
is gone all those trillions of dollars
will be printed they've been eaten up by
people buying burka bags and Nikes and
Dom P it's gone it's been consumed and
so that's why we're seeing what we're
seeing and I think you'll find options
and my friend after we do here we'll go
into the back
Ray Ray such a pleasure
[Music]
making the creative is not free
except if you use employees that are
still around doing nothing
but
good
maybe people run it differently so um
[Music]
they say half of all that out
right and you know that was built on the
concept of the way television ads ran
and no measurement that was pre-internet
we do not have to live in that world
anymore
how do you know
that what you're doing let's talk about
it in detail notice how earlier I said
you've got to make sure you're strategic
about the URL
if if the URL in your social media
accounts goes to a landing page with a
Google Voice phone number or a different
phone number than every other part of
your business and a different website
than people sign up for for your
business you can track every single
dollar coming from that channel
you're welcome sir
no it's it's a really great question
it's a great question and it's real
what's Siri is how real what I'm talking
about is but let there be no confusion
to your point when it was Mad Men how
many people watched Mad Men on that show
so you have good context that was fun
drink bourbon have sex make up ideas
that's why people got into Marketing in
the 60s 70s 80s it was cool it's not as
cool anymore it's hard now
and it's so much more complex let there
be no confusion I understand I spoke
about it as the way I spoke about it
because the concept is super simple and
right
but no different than somebody going on
a workout regimen like great it's simple
have a good ratio of protein versus
carbs go into the jail like the math
like the regimen's simple
but there's a reason people choose
steroids and [ __ ] plastic surgery the
shit's hard
and so same with this it's not easy per
se but man when it works it's very real
and I think the land grab of 2023 is
going to be substantial the thing I
started with I'm glad I'm here now not
two years ago everything I just talked
about really is going to play out next
year in a much bigger way and for the
one percent of this audience that's
actually gonna do anything about what I
just talked about they're gonna get out
sized Returns on it
here we go I'm totally gonna help myself
I stopped following you four years ago
yes sir uh that's okay that's good just
not sure because in some ways in some
ways you're fantastic that's the way it
should be humans shouldn't agree on
everything and the sooner we figure that
out the sooner we'll all be much happier
the audacity that people in here think
that people should see the world exactly
how they see that is pretty scary but
nonetheless sir
I'd love to have a happiness competition
with you and so then I'm like yes let's
compete on it anyway
the question I had is
brushed up against it twice in the last
20 minutes
College yes uh 12 year old and a 10 year
old lovely job I'm getting to the point
where I'm almost recommending that don't
go to college
love to hear your thoughts
it's that I think humans should never
fit in one size fits all I think many of
us
you know I think
who's 45 or older raise your hands so
for everybody who raised their hand
including me we all grew up where there
was no other option it couldn't even
clear one of our heads that one would
not go to college it'd be like not
breathing oxygen it was like completely
unacceptable I think how old are you my
friend
41. I think your kids
are going to be the generation of
parents that bring this number all the
way down to 30 to 50 percent of people
that go to college
not because College isn't good college
is amazing for certain people
but college is not amazing for a lot of
other people and what got me going
because I produce a lot of content
around College was all I do is listen
and then I talk
so I was getting hundreds of DMS from
kids who were 26 25 27 who had 50 60 100
000 in debt couldn't get a job nobody
cared outside of the top 15 colleges in
America after that it's like almost
completely irrelevant right and most
companies I mean vaynermedia doesn't
work we have I have no idea what college
any of my employees go to Facebook
Google these are real companies now not
requiring college education I think the
cat's out of the bag the way College was
structured I mean I I'm a big fan of
common sense I think common sense is
super underrated
I when I found out when I was like 27
that you could be a fraud to clear
bankruptcy and be okay to start over but
you could never
declare bankruptcy or clean your college
debt I was like some shit's [ __ ] up
with that
so I think we had heavy propaganda which
is fine I could get really served the
purpose I'm sure the people that are 60
and older in this crowd will tell you
everybody that went to college in the
70s and 80s when they got that diploma
there was an Roi on that and it worked
out that is not 2023 and we have a lot
of children
who are like me who get no value from a
box education system can't learn that
way aren't getting any value they have
the internet I yeah I think I think
you're barking up a potential tree but
I'll give you my example my kids are the
same age one of my kids is moonwalking
to college and she will dominate the
other one
I think he's got a chance of not going
and he may go because it's a four-year
vacation
like he may go because it's a fort like
to me I would tell if my son was 18
today I would say do what I did it was
the last four year vacation in my life I
played Madden and hung out all day
because I knew I was going to work from
22 to 100 and maybe it's worth it and
that's what I think it is like the
hardest thing like the only thing I'm
not interested in the world is to tell
someone how to parent their child it's
completely ridiculous but there are
macro themes and I do think there are
people in here who get bought into
propagandas that become religion and
that's good like some of it's very
positive but some of it can be negative
the thought here's the one that bothers
me to no end parents have forced their
kids to go to college
and don't pay for it
are pieces of [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's one thing if you're like very big
on College and you need it and you force
your kid then you better at least pay
for that [ __ ] because the ROI the math
is very clear right the math is very
clear it is not working for a lot of
people the fact that we even have to
have a debate that the government's
going to bail out people with college
think about that think about how bad
this has gotten and worst of all forget
about money [ __ ] money these kids are
deeply unhappy that
to go there they have so much more
creative Firepower
Gary they get to meet people and it's
the community I'm like so is going to
Europe for the summer
like the prop you know like yeah that's
where I'm at
[Applause]
Gary what's that uh I've been fortunate
institution since the early one Library
days I'm humbled and please
[Music]
since we are at a fitness convention
I've got a I give you some props around
how cut you look thank you
it's a lot better than my 2009 videos
yeah I think we need to do a little more
before and after marketing at X go and I
think a photo of you now person that's
going to be pretty funny well it's funny
brother just to jump in to get valued
everybody that's why I'm so passionate
about the marketing stuff nothing comes
less than me than the process I've gone
through in the last eight years to get
into better physical health my brain
goes to if I figured this out at
starting at 38 after doing nothing I had
0.0 muscle in my body at 38 and only
consumed soda and sugar until my face
fell off
for me to be able to win that game makes
me feel that anybody here who's like I
don't like technology I don't like this
like is capable of winning this if they
want what's wrong why did I do it
because I'd like to live longer why am I
asking you to do this because you'd like
your business to be better
so um
you know back then you're still here now
a lot of new voices the grid also
um
but what I really appreciate is your
tongue has changed over the years a
little bit when you've added in the
emotional intelligence piece you go deep
in happiness and that would have been a
lot of fluff back in 2009
and I think it's overlooked by a lot of
people
so Props to usually have thank you thank
you
when I'm getting out of here is my wife
and I and our portfolio we have a couple
pure bars shout out to your car
real quick on that can I recommend to
the people in the back I think you guys
and gals should have a summer camp where
the brands compete with each other
winner takes off
I know they're like we're just one happy
family I'm like yeah but competition's
the [ __ ] best
all right go ahead
so uh
[Music]
the new former team that we've had the
last couple years amazing thank you most
of our ownership faced is a badass woman
and um I'm really proud of my wife and
but she's go go in most of the ownership
faces
and put everyone else first yep
customers their teams yeah their kids
all this other [ __ ] you know is it them
so I would love for you to speak to
not just manage your managers but speak
to meet yourself and how you do that
it's called Happiness
so love you so a couple things great
great stuff a couple things similar to
college
like for some of us me included go go go
is the happiness
I try to tell a lot of my friends
they're like Gary you need to pick up
golf I'm like [ __ ] off
I don't like golf like you love golf and
the fact that for four hours that's your
escapism for me my hobby my hobby is
business
so for the same way people like skiing
and cooking and golf like for some of us
in this room the go go is the happiness
the reason if you pick up the context of
what I just talked about the reason I've
always done what I've done is because I
love it
when I'm when you're nine and it snows
and you don't want to make a snowman and
go sledding but you want to ring
doorbells and shovel snow like that's
just in you and so for me first for the
people that are Partners or have loved
ones that go go don't eliminate the com
the thought that maybe
that's just their great love that the
work is their hobby that exists I'm one
of those people on the flip side
I've watched too many friends and
contemporaries burn out if you die
your business is closed anyway
like if you don't like it this is a very
simple thing for me everything works
because I love it
but if you don't like it and you're
doing it for the money you're in deep
[ __ ] it's not sustainable you are
vulnerable it won't work it may work for
six years it may work for nine years but
it won't work
I also think like as we go through our
Journeys you know for me to your point
from 2009
as if you remember it was similar to
what I think we might be walking into we
had the 2008 crash nobody knew the
internet think about what I'm talking
about here today when I was talking
about that in 2008 and saying you can
make money on YouTube people laughed at
me so I was very passionate to be like
hey I know you lost your job but it's
not the end of the world you can go hard
you can get a lower paying job during
the day and if you want to get out of it
you can do something you love from 7 P.M
to midnight
the emotional intelligent thing was as
things were working more for me by 2012
1417 I was like there's other things
here that I'm doing well that I don't
really even realize it was subconscious
I was always nice I was always simple I
was always humble I just wasn't talking
about it because I didn't realize I was
as I go through the next 50 years of my
life I'm going to talk about the things
I observe you know this I didn't talk
about college I started talking about it
once ten thousand people sent me
messages that they were miserable one of
the biggest reasons I'm scared of people
who are entitled and the fact that
parents don't teach accountability why
do I pick on eighth place trophies I
pick on eighth place trophies because I
know unlimited 25 year olds in the world
are anxious because they're scared of
losing because an entire generation of
parents demonized losing when you should
be making your kids lose 24 7 365.
everyone's like social media's got these
kids [ __ ] up no no I love when Boomers
and older Millennials are like [ __ ]
these gen Z kids I'm like you [ __ ]
raise them [ __ ]
maybe if you didn't want your kid your
kid sucked at soccer
but you wanted them to get a trophy but
they [ __ ] sucked at soccer
don't you think that's [ __ ] up
so you didn't want them to cry little
tears when they were little now they're
crying big tears when they're big
kids are scared out here because they
think losing's bad losing is the best
losing is the [ __ ] best you want me
to leave with something losing is the
[ __ ] best
you know why a lot of you are going to
try some of the stuff I talked about and
for most of you it's not gonna work
because you're not good enough at it
you're not good what do you think you're
gonna make a [ __ ] Tick Tock tomorrow
and you're gonna be [ __ ] Charlie
[ __ ] demilio
I've been doing this [ __ ] for my whole
life I've been making social media
content for 15 years every day 15 times
15 365 times 15 years
you gotta get on the [ __ ] treadmill
most of your marketing
is like you're 637 pounds
you've got a lot of work to do it's
gonna take time to get down to your
natural body weight but if you don't get
on the treadmill it will never happen
so guess what the next year is going to
be a lot of losing you know what else
hurts you're really you know you decide
Gary got you and now you're nice as [ __ ]
after being somewhat neutral to maybe
not great and now you're nicest [ __ ] to
your employee and after nine months they
quit and go to a competitor the first
thing you're gonna think is [ __ ] Gary
thank you
that's losing but it's a micro loss we
have to understand what a micro loss is
versus a macro loss you figure that [ __ ]
out you'll be real happy
I was really happy to be with you thank
you